so today we're talk about how SIBO can
steal your nutrients SIBO is small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth okay and
basically that is this normally your
flora your good friendly bacteria should
be on the large intestines right through
here but when it gets into the small
intestines it becomes this and what
happens is when you eat these microbes
start fermenting carbohydrates they
start eating up your nutrients
especially b12 iron and bile so bloating
abdominal pain and gas are just one side
effect but a bigger side effect is the
nutritional deficiencies so when you're
deficient in b12 you can have all sorts
of things from serious neurological
issues shooting stabbing pain to anemia
and the list goes on and on on and then
iron anemia fatigue and then when you're
deficient in bile you no longer can
digest your fats and you can't extract
fat Seibel vitamins so you become
deficient in vitamin A vitamin D vitamin
E and vitamin K as well as essential
fatty acids and there's so many symptoms
that are associated with those nutrients
so what causes SIBO well it could come
from many different things one being
some complication after surgery because
they structurally altered your digestive
system and sometimes that physical
alteration allows the bacteria to escape
going backwards into the small intestine
where you have this huge problem it
could also come from not having enough
stomach acid normally in the stomach the
pH should be between one and three this
is very very acidic and one of the big
purposes of having a really strong
acidic stomach is to kill off microbes
so if you don't have that acid the
microbes that come from the food go into
the stomach and invade the small
intestine and start to multiply and
start living down here alright so now
what do you do about this condition
number one you need to increase the
acidity of your stomach very very
important I would start with something
called betaine hydrochloride you can get
them in pills I would take at least five
before
each meal I would also take out soda
vinegar as well on a regular basis you
can even get pills that combine outside
of vinegar powder with betaine
hydrochloride and take them together
that will start helping this area right
here number two you want to do
intermittent fasting this gives your
digestive system a chance to reset and
clean out some of the food for the
microbes and allow the transit time and
the food to kind of get through down
into the small intestine through here
now one of the things that happens when
you do in a minute fasting is you have
this kind of this washing effect of the
food back into the large intestine which
happened from these little cilia hairs
so you get this cleaning effect if you
could do in a minute fasting long enough
very very important compared to eat
eating so frequently if you're not doing
in a minute fasting I believe you can
never fully handle this condition next
thing is to avoid prebiotics and I'm
talking about fiber do not consume fiber
and I'm talking about vegetables as well
for at least a month to six weeks
because guess what these microbes live
on that fiber they'll ferment the fiber
and you'll get gas and that also goes
for probiotics don't take probiotics
because we're trying to avoid adding
more bacteria you already have too much
bacteria and the microbes that are in
there don't like to be in there and you
have unfriendly ones as well so this
huge competition and definitely don't
consume something that combines both of
these a pre and a probiotic together
that would be like sauerkraut that would
really create a bloating effect the last
thing I would recommend is some type of
herbal antibiotic I mean you can do
oregano thyme clove garlic and that will
create an environment that's very
antimicrobial so that's what you want so
in summary I want to emphasize that this
condition is actually way more common
than you might think and number two one
of the big problems with this condition
is the nutrition deficiencies that a lot
of people don't realize that could be
creating symptoms that you're not aware
of so those nutritional deficiencies are
not coming because you're not eating
certain foods they're coming because the
microbes are actually eating them up and
they're not giving them to you now
there's a lot more to this
as far as getting tests to determine if
you have it or not I put some links down
below for some additional information
thanks for watching hey if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos